at this year's chemistry meeting in
Germany our young scientists put pairs
of Nobel Prize winners on the spot in
four debates they asked just how science
can help solve important problems in the
real world
I'm still a proponent for the purely
electrical way so use the electricity
for the water hikes generate electricity
and then you charge better based across
the weak point is the battle is there
I'm very optimistic that this is solved
sooner and what do you think about
hydrogen based fueling system because we
can produce the hydrogen and we are more
and more able to put the system more
efficiently you know I would test for
scientists if you're working on every
day s what's the price point in the
production of hydrogen per kilogram I
think three dollars yeah we don't know
six dollars hopeless it's not gonna get
started it's like if I produce biofuels
at six dollars a gallon
you never you're gonna get started if
you don't know that you should start
knowing that
TB and HIV are real problems which need
urgent attention
I think we need to provide a platform of
a good communication where scientists
are involved in government and
government is involved in basic
disappearance so you have two categories
scientists and governments and in your
premium they should talk they should be
a platform a very very thick layer in
between which are the people that do and
these are the industrialists these are
the companies these are the
intrapreneurs this is the intermediate
between them in a poorer country even in
a country like India it's not so easy to
convince the corporate private sector to
finance something that doesn't have
immediate result
shitman was quite inspiring on the fact
that okay you don't have to wait for the
government or the you know funding
bodies to go but they do but the thing
is all these research things where they
haven't when these other industries
haven't come in because they won't
because there's no money to be made yes
there's no-one to exploit in these
things so that's where you need these
other policy solutions
I'm studying nitrogenase for the same
reason of wanting to make catalysts that
are more efficient it's really
interesting that scientists have been
studying this problem for a really long
time you said yourself that it took 70
years to understand the mechanisms right
yeah and it's it's almost impossible
from fundamental research to predict how
you can increase your activity by one
percent yeah this is trial and error
I used to consult for people in industry
who would do heterogeneous catalysis and
you know you talk and they would say I
did a little barium and it got better so
I added some more they got better what
should I do next and you know you had
we're barium who knows why but it works
so it used to be a black ops totally
black yeah right in some ways it seems
like it still is topic of our discussion
should be antibiotic resistance we have
to do something about it otherwise we're
gonna have a huge antibiotic resistance
pandemic my hypothesis is even worse
than yours I think that two three
decades and we come back to the middle
of last century before the biotics we
are stepping to that side if there if
situation continues is now where the
academics and working on this problem
working on cancer that's considered very
prestigious right working on antibiotic
resistance like you kind of like you
know raise your eyebrows a little bit
when you hear someone doing that I'm
surprised I mean I think it's a big
problem and I think I think the general
community recognizes it and in fact if
you're treating patients with cancer
you're reducing their immune function
everybody recognizes that a very
important I fully agree with you the
resistant goes because bacteria want to
live and they know how to do it
you